the hate Trump media mob they're up to
the same old tricks all week
they have been breathlessly pushing at
another anonymously anonymously source
unverified rumor when will they learn
about the contents of the Muller report
we're going to address the hysteria in
just a moment it just keep lying making
it up right but first we have actual
news to report the crisis at our
southern border is now spiraling out of
control where do you see the video we
have for you tonight exclusively for
Hannity and President Trump put Mexico
on notice take a look we're going to
give them a one-year warning and if the
drugs don't stop were largely stop we're
going to put tariffs on Mexico and
products in particular cars the whole
ballgame is cars it's the big ballgame
with many countries it's cars and if
that doesn't stop the drugs we close the
border government of Mexico must be held
accountable interestingly they have some
of the toughest laws against the illegal
immigration of any country now they have
one year now to get their act together
but really the answer is securing our
southern border Kendall longer wait and
today during a raid ice agents look at
this they arrested 280 illegal
immigrants working at only one company
in Texas the largest worksite operation
in more than a decade in Louisiana a
previously deported illegal immigrant
was arrested get this on more than a
hundred child sex crime charges
including sexual battery of a child
under the age of 13 illegal immigration
is seeing a massive spike ports of
entries are overwhelmed with traffic
they believe Trump is doing this because
they see it and our federal governments
catch and release program sadly is
expanded that means thousands of illegal
immigrants or simply just let free in
the United States pending a court date
that they'll never show up at and guess
what they failed to show up to court oh
let's see ninety-five percent of the
time and as we speak people from all
over the world are literally walking
into the united states because we have
unprotected areas of our border
last night during a ride-along with
Border Patrol officers in Texas our very
own Lawrence Jones witnessed two men
from China walking across the shallow
Rio Grande before being apprehended
we're gonna have the full footage of
that coming up and you're not gonna
believe what Lawrence also witnessed and
the exclusive video we have first we
turn to our Hannity watch though on the
radical 20/20 Democratic socialists
three more women now now accuse creepy
crazy uncle Joe Biden of making them
feel uncomfortable this is now a grand
total of seven and President Trump is Oh
openly mocking creepy Uncle Joe on
Twitter earlier today the president
posted this video showing the former
vice president getting well the Biden
treatment four hours later piden
responded quote I see that you were on
the job and presidential as always okay
Joe you're gonna have a tough time
against this president trust me if
that's your answer but the point is
creepy crazy Uncle Joe is really gonna
what show Donald Trump had to be
President is that how I mean nothing
says presidential like invading somebody
space smelling their hair rubbing noses
locking lips and unsolicited back rubs
but by the way where is Obama he hasn't
said a word yet sticking up for his
favorite creepy Uncle Joe now if Biden
does want to officially throw his hat
into the ring he's soon really gonna
need to rub shoulders with the
democratic party's chief kingmaker now
of course would be the reverend al
sharpton US News will report calling it
the al Sharpton primary this week twelve
Democratic candidates twelve of them are
speaking at Sharpton's National Action
Network convention but the ring kissing
doesn't stop there no Reverend Sharpton
said well Sean Hannity's been there yeah
I went there to debate him and confront
him with his own words by the way that
was so popular that there were literally
hundreds and thousands of people outside
knocking on the door led us in room was
packed and Bose O'Rourke reportedly
personally promising Sharpton to pursue
reparations as president you might
remember senator Kamala
is dining with al sharpton in an
infamous harlem restaurant just before
she kicked off her campaign and
according to the Los Angeles Times New
York senator Kirsten Gillibrand never
forgets the call Sharpton on his
birthday remember we're talking about
the Reverend Al Sharpton again he's a
tinfoil hat conspiracy TV MSNBC got to
start promoting really controversial
things like in the Tawana Brawley case
or Freddie's fashion Martin 120 Fifth
Street in New York also accused of
fomenting violence if you remember
against Jewish Americans during the 91
Crown Heights riots in New York City
saying quote if the Jews want to get it
on
tell them to pin their yarmulkes back
and come on over to my house pretty
disgusting pretty hate-filled and this
is not the language well frankly nothing
for Reverend Sharpton the person whose
ring they're kissing
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that'll be the 2020 kingmaker or
the Democratic Party that is the man
that virtually every single candidate is
now bowing down to this is really a
radical extreme Democratic Socialist
Party speaking of which their fearless
leader on Capitol Hill freshman
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo Cortez
once again predicting the end of days
this time she did it while treating her
fans to a lengthy Instagram live session
where she gulped down wine and was
assembling furniture from I guess IKEA
and for you know I guess a brand new
luxury apartment in DC this goes off the
rails take a look how many years until
the world ends again we have 12 years
left to cut emissions by at least 50%
if not more you may laugh but your
grandkids will not the apocalypse is
imminent the world ends in 12 years
congresswoman Acacio Cortes assembling
furniture but don't worry America you
are in great hands no oil no gas no
combustion engine no planes no cows
we're gonna show you all of the worst
moments from that ranting mini monologue
of the congresswoman honestly it would
be kind of hilarious except for the fact
that Acacio Cortes is calling the shots
she is the leader of the Democratic
Party Nancy Pelosi is scared to death as
I've been saying
avocado Cortes and meanwhile the
extension of the Democratic Party yes
the mainstream media mob the rage trump
media mob they are up to their same old
shameful behavior after spending over
two years reporting nothing but baseless
rumors conspiracies anonymous sources
wild speculation Trump Russia
illusion yes the medium mob ended up
looking pretty stupid and very partisan
as it turns out there was no collusion
none that's clear
Robert Muller determined that and there
was no obstruction it was all a giant
hoax perpetrated by Trump haters but
that's not stopping these same outlets
from doing the exact same thing and
starting all over again
we had an FBI investigation to
congressional investigations and the
Muller report Washington Post New York
Times both reporting that some a
Muller's team are claiming the special
counsels findings are actually more
damning than what the Attorney General
bar revealed in his summary and that the
report will show the Trump may-maybe did
commit obstruction in some ways once
again reports are based on hearsay from
anonymous sources or maybe it was GD Ray
who Muller hired Clinton's old attorney
or Andrew Weissman was waiting at
Hillary Clinton's victory party New York
Times conspiracy theorist Paul Krugman
tweeting that the reports quote must be
presumed true really until proven false
from the same New York Times that got
everything wrong up to this point now
until you realize that Muller
did not charge the president with
anything nothing and the investigation
after bar and rod Rosen Stein waited on
obstruction pretty much within seconds
it's over whether they like it or not
let's just buy into their fantasy though
for a second let's pretend The Times and
The Washington Post let's say their
stories are true let's say they got a
leak from someone on the Democratic
Mullard team all right they wanted to
get this information out and an FBI
investigation must be launched
immediately because that is a serious
illegal leak in and of itself of course
the Attorney General bar has promised to
release the full molar report in a few
weeks after redacting as recommended oh
by even the cowardly Schiff himself and
Democrats that was so angry they thought
that sources and methods were revealed
by Republicans but they don't care about
this in this case well and they didn't
want the star
for doubt either about 17 current
Democrats will soon know what's in that
report but it doesn't matter
there's no indictment the media the
Democrat they just wait and analyze
Muller's findings we'll see what the
documents say but no sore losers on the
left the ones that could never accept
Donald Trump one they're trying to keep
hope alive and speculation with rumors
with hearsay anonymous sources just like
they've been doing for two plus years
dozen stories and dozens stories about
Russia Trump collusion stories about Don
jr. Michael Cole visiting Prague I knew
Michael Kohn was in Los Angeles at the
time to fake reports about the mooch
Anthony scaramouche II to the President
himself fake news after fake news
journalism in America's dead and buried
and you know something for two years on
this program we have built in a real
investigative reporting team we have
been proven right there's not a single
newsroom in America that has been more
right than the team we have assembled
right here on this show and I am really
proud of that fact and here's more news
we will be proven even more right in the
days weeks months ahead as we now see
the FISA warrants the gang of eight
material as we begin to dig deep into
the 302s in other words the information
that has been sitting there that will be
coming out for example FISA abuse
committing fraud on a FISA Court rigging
an investigation into a preferred
presidential candidate if all these
people the news if they really care
about obstruction really that they
really think that that is an important
issue how come that none of them has
ever talked about the fact that James
commis lead counsel had counseled the
FBI James Baker wanted to indict Hillary
because he believed she violated the
Espionage Act that would be a crime and
also that Hillary literally and her team
deleted 30,000 subpoenaed emails
acid-washed her hard drive with bleach
pit
beat up had an aide beat up or
BlackBerry's and phones with hammers and
remove the SIM cards that's the biggest
slam-dunk obstruction case I've ever
heard of does the media that is back to
their their tin foil hat conspiracies
that they ever report this do they
really care about obstruction or is it
sort of like they only care about
beating up Trump like for example they
want to beat up justice Cavanaugh and
they want to beat up any Republican any
accusation against any Republican why
are the I believe people so quiet as it
relates to the lieutenant governor of
the Commonwealth of Virginia oh it only
care if it's a Republican that's
involved I got it
if they care about dreamers daca and the
second term of Barack Obama they
actually care about building a wall in
they're willing to fund it they don't
really care about dreamers docker or
building the wall because Donald Trump
supports it their rage for Trump goes
that deep that's how hypocritical they
are